in this video we're going to talk about
sources of genetic variation which is
key for evolution and natural selection
to happen just as a little bit of a
primer natural selection you can have a
bunch of different organisms with
different genetics different genotypes
and they can express themselves as
different phenotypes and i'll just do
this as different colored circles right
over here so there are all of these
different phenotypes and i'm just
expressing different phenotypes of one
trait and then depending on what's going
on in the environment some of these
phenotypes might be more favorable for
survival and reproducing and therefore
passing on those genes to the next
generation and if you do that over many
many many many generations you can have
a change in your gene pool because the
genes that provide the variance of
phenotypes that are more successful will
exist more but an interesting question
is where does this variation come from
and there's several sources of it so one
of the key and probably the most
primitive version of genetic variation
is mutation
cells are incredibly accurate when they
are copying dna but there are going to
be some errors now most of these errors
can oftentimes break the organism in
some way or might not matter at all but
every now and then some of these errors
either as an individual base pair change
or maybe cumulatively can produce a
different phenotype and potentially a
phenotype that has an advantage and so
this has always been the case
now another major source of genetic
variation is sexual reproduction
and to remind ourselves of sexual
reproduction i will show you this
diagram of meiosis
now sexual reproduction is the process
by which we form gametes so for a male
organism that would be producing the
sperm cells or for a female organism
that would be producing the egg cells
this meiosis diagram is for an organism
that has two
pairs of chromosomes while we know that
human beings actually have 23 pairs but
if we saw a diagram of 23 pairs it would
get very complicated very fast so the
two pairs help us understand what's
going on and help us understand where
some of this genetic variation is going
to come from so i've already pre-labeled
the homologous chromosomes here and just
as a reminder homologous chromosomes are
ones that have the same genes on them
now they could have different versions
of the genes on them but they're
fundamentally coding for the same genes
you can view chromosomes as really long
stretches of dna
that has all been
rolled in and bunched in together
something like this a human chromosome
can have on the order of a hundred
million base pairs in it now if you were
to straighten that string of dna if you
were to unwind it you would see
different sections code for different
genes so that might be one gene there
that might be another gene there you
might have one long gene right over
there on average the genes are about 27
000 base pairs in length but some of
them could be millions of base pairs so
on one of these chromosomes you can
actually have thousands of genes being
coded and so if you were to pick this
chromosome and this chromosome right
over here they would be coding for the
same genes because they're homologous
but once again they could have different
alleles different versions of those
genes on them and similarly this
chromosome
and this chromosome are also homologous
they're also coding for the same genes
now as we go into meiosis the first step
is that the chromosomes are essentially
going to copy themselves into two sister
chromatids so
for example
this one right over here has now copied
itself and it has that telltale x shape
but this side of this now chromosome
which we would call a chromatid and this
sister chromatid should be identical now
there might be some errors that got
introduced through mutation but if we
don't assume mutation they would be
identical likewise this side
and this side assuming no mutations they
would be identical
now what's interesting about this is
what happens in the next phase
in the next phase you have the
independent assortment of homologous
chromosomes so as we said
this
and this might be coding for the same
genes it might just have different
versions but as we go into this phase as
we do meiosis one as it's often known
right over here this blue chromosome
could go here while the homologous red
chromosome would go there the purple
chromosome is going here and the light
blue chromosome is going there and this
is really interesting because there's a
lot of different ways this could happen
in this situation you have two pairs
each of these intermediary steps in
meiosis could randomly have one from
each pair so just in this example you
have two to the number of pairs
combinations at this stage right over
here now this was only when we have two
pairs if we're talking about a human
being we're talking about two to the
23rd different combinations of which of
the two homologous chromosomes you get
so there's a lot of variation here
now on top of that some of y'all might
have noticed something interesting
if you just follow the colors here it
looks like a little chunk of this
chromosome got swapped with a little
chunk of this chromosome you could see
it here the red is now on the big blue x
and the blue is now on the big red x
this is another source of genetic
variation and it is known as crossover
and what it does is it can actually mix
dna between chromosomes once again these
are homologous chromosomes they are
encoding the same genes but now alleles
that were sitting on the blue one could
now sit with the rest of the red one and
the alleles that were sitting with the
red one can now sit with the rest of the
blue ones and crossover is actually
reasonably common during meiosis so once
again it's mixing things up even more
than this 2 to the 23rd combinations so
a lot of variation that you can produce
through sexual reproduction and then as
we go into this last phase into meiosis
ii and we're actually producing the
gametes if this meiosis is going on in
the gonads of a male this would be the
chromosomal makeup of the sperm cells if
this is going on within the female then
this would be the dna makeup of the egg
cells
and what you see and just to make it
clear what's happened here is that your
sister chromatids have now spread apart
although they're no longer identical
especially if you have the crossover so
for example this one went over here
and this one
went over here as well
and then you have another scenario where
you have this one
and this one ended up in this gamete and
we can go on and on so actually you can
have especially if you consider
crossover more than 2 to the 23rd
possible combinations now 2 to the 23rd
power is approximately a little bit more
than 8 million
combinations and if you want a little
math trick for estimating powers of 2
you can just recognize that 2 to the
10th power is a little bit more than a
thousand so this is going to be 2 to the
20th which is about a million and then 2
to the third which is 8 so a little bit
more than 8 million and once again
that's before considering crossover and
mutation which is going to make the
combinations even larger and i'll also
point out these are the combinations for
the gametes and the gametes are haploid
they have half the dna of a full
organism and so when the gametes combine
you're actually going to have 2 to the
23rd times 2 to the 23rd combinations
just from sexual reproduction and you'll
have even more for mutation and
crossover and so that's going to lead
you to more than 70 trillion
combinations just from these two parents